l'origine on a du mal à finir nos années
comme on est ce qu'on appelle en
carrière longue et active c'est quoi
pour un pompier une carrière longue qui
fait une carrière longue c'est que vous
commencez pompier vous finissez pompier
bah c'est là je minimum légal de départ
en retraite c'est 57 ans d'accord
c'est-à-dire que quand vous avez tout
votre trimestre vous pouvez partir mais
la plupart d'entre nous nous les ont pas
donc on continue 58 58 et demi donc ça
c'est la réalité actuelle avec des
grosses difficultés bien sûr
tout au long de notre carrière on subit
tout un ensemble de choses et que soit
psychologique ou physique vous imaginez
bien que déjà alors qu'il est avec en
finissant à 58 ans on y va presque on se
traînant pour certains d'entre nous avec
avec des douleurs et des gens qui vont
pas très bien donc vous imaginez qu'avec
deux ans de plus ça sera 60-61 ans dans
les mêmes conditions et c'est vraiment
je vous dis c'est pas possible donc
c'est très fort
comme beaucoup dans beaucoup de métiers
beaucoup de profession elle est basée
que sur la finance et pas sur la santé
des gens
et on n'écoute pas les gens et donc il y
a des gens qui en fait la pénibilité du
travail n'est pas pris du tout en compte
en fait non bien sûr c'est ça c'est ça
de votre retraite qui vous choque c'est
le fait que il y a beaucoup de sujets il
y a beaucoup de sujets là sur la
question posée
c'est que physiquement c'est pas
possible voilà tout simplement c'est
combien le montant de la retraite d'un
pompier c'est combien bah ça va entre
1800 et 2000 euros d'accord voilà pour
les primo intervenants voilà les gens
qui a dans les véhicules après qu'on
vous passez il y a des officiers qui
gagnent un peu plus et ainsi de suite ça
monte bien sûr comme dans toutes les
hiérarchies bien sûr est-ce que en tant
que pièce que vous faites partie des du
cortège des manifestants ou pas du tout
bien sûr bien sûr on a été sur les
pompiers
parce qu'on est visible voilà on est
protégé et nous bien sûr c'était de
d'être vu voilà j'étais dans ce groupe
là là
là devant pour protester contre la
réforme bien sûr bien sûr qu'on accepte
pas parce qu'on a un métier dangereux
qui est pénible on cumule tous les
risques professionnels et donc ça c'est
pas acceptable et donc nous c'est nous
quoi voilà tout simplement vous êtes
accueillis comment dans les
manifestations très très bien sûr quand
il voit les gens ils sont ils sont
heureux ils sont contents et ils savent
aussi parce que ça nous est arrivé
j'ai une petite anecdote la première
manifestation il y avait tellement de
monde que les gens ils étaient écrasés
des uns sur les autres et donc on a fini
donc je vais les citer un Pizza Pino
place de la République avec 6 ou 7
personnes qui faisaient des malaises
dont voilà qui a été transporté merci à
eux en tout cas de m'avoir accueilli on
va citer d'autres
cité la pizza c'est pas grave on a aussi
travaillé à pizza Tino et pizza Patrick
nous ont bien accueilli ils ont un
paysage
vous allez continuer la mobilisation
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr qu'on a
continué on ira jusqu'au bout on
baissera pas les bras voilà il y a le
futur vous des Jeux Olympiques on va
avoir besoin de nous bien sûr qu'est-ce
que vous attendez du gouvernement parce
que aujourd'hui c'est ce que je dis à
chaque fois j'en parle avec vous voilà
Alexandre et Grégory ce soir là ça va
passer bien entendu devant le Conseil
constitutionnel il y a très peu de
chances que ce soit rotoqué donc
forcément elle va risque de de passer
cette réforme des retraites qu'est-ce
qui aujourd'hui est-ce que vous dites on
descend dans la rue pour faire avancer
les choses bien ce que vous dites on
descend dans la rue pour faire entendre
notre voix mais ça changera rien de
toute façon le gouvernement a montré une
certaine fermeté une grosse fermeté sur
sur cette décision et apparemment ils
ont pas l'intention de de refaire en
arrière parce que c'est vrai que moi
j'ai envie d'avoir la vie d'un pompier
aussi parce que il y a il y avait au
niveau livre qui était là un citoyen
engagé la semaine dernière qui nous
disait nous on va on va aller encore de
plus en plus loin dans dans
les actions est-ce que vous vous dites
NON continuera à descendre dans la rue
pacifiquement comme vous le faites et
c'est très bien et ça va faire avancer
les choses
en fait on est tous conscients que il y
a quelque chose à faire sur la retraite
et qui a une réforme à faire après
malgré tout il y a des professions qui
peuvent continuer et d'autres qui
peuvent donc ça c'est un fait tous les
gens de terrain qui sont dehors là on
voit les éboueurs on voit les gens du
bâtiment les gens qui ont des métiers
dit vraiment difficile
pas mal de services publics pour pas les
citer la fonction publique hospitalière
à laquelle qui est au bout du bout
bien évidemment qu'il faut il se passe
quelque chose donc
nous clairement on attend qui retire
qu'on rediscute un peu sur la pénibilité
sur des critères des critères qui sont
évidents la femme carrière la fin de
carrière chez nous elle est elle est
compliquée elle est très difficile parce
que des places entre guillemets dans les
bureaux les emplois réservés ce qu'on
appelle qui sont en train de disparaître
donc on va faire quoi de nous il faut
savoir une chose qui est très importante
si on est apparemment les seuls dans
cette situation c'est que si vous
finissez pas pompier le jour de votre
retraite
que vous ne puissiez pas ou que vous ne
vouliez pas c'est-à-dire vous les
quittez le métier en fait tout au long
de notre retraite seront on a ce qu'on
appelle des années de bonification c'est
pour ça qu'on part à 57 ans c'est à dire
que on fait 27 ans de service actifs
donc c'était 25 ans avec la réforme des
deux ans dernier vous êtes vous partez 5
ans avant
c'est une spécificité si jamais on
quitte les pompiers avant notre retraite
on perd ses cinq années donc on part à
64 donc en fait c'est quelle
reconnaissance on a de ce gouvernement
très sincèrement qu'elle reconnaissances
alors je vais vous montrer autre chose
je vais vous montrer une vidéo et
regarder bien cette vidéo il est 21h05
on est on est en direct à Rennes des
pompiers ont été insultés par des
manifestants aujourd'hui alors que qu'il
faisait leur travail regardez cette
vidéo
[Musique]
vous dites quoi ce genre de l'analyse
elle est simple elle est comme souvent
c'est à dire que leurs moyens de
s'exprimer c'est de brûler de casser dès
que nous on doit intervenir forcément
c'est ce qui les met en évidence dans
les médias la preuve c'est filmé donc
bien sûr que bah il s'en prennent à nous
ils essaient de nous empêcher de le
faire c'est arrivé à Paris plusieurs
fois et c'est arrivé dans plein de
départements pour les mêmes raisons mais
foncièrement ils en veulent pas aux
pompiers mais il y a toujours dans le
dans l'assemblée des manifestants des
gens bien sûr qu'il lâchent des mots des
insultes bien sûr qu'est-ce qu'on vous
dit
on ressent alors il y a toutes sortes de
mots mais on ressent bien en fait que
parce qu'on fait ça parce qu'on est
appelé pour faire ça évidemment il y a
un amalgame qui se fait avec le
gouvernement et puis et puis quand il y
a les forces de l'ordre on prend au même
titre que les forces de l'ordre voilà
qui sont là pour nous sécuriser mais à
la finale on prend pareil voilà pompier
c'est toujours un métier qui est qui a
toujours fait rêver tous les enfants
veulent devenir pompier pas qu'il y a
énormément de Burn Out et de plus en
plus en ce moment chez
je suis chez vos collègues ouais bien
sûr bon il y a eu l'obligation vaccinale
qu'on a fait partir pas mal qui a mis
des gens dans les situations très
complexes
qui en a quand même qui voilà qui ont
refusé donc le faire vacciner et qui
sont dû quitter leur fonction ouais
c'est ça voilà et aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'ils sont toujours pas réintégrés ils
ont été suspendus donc déjà il y a ça
après il y a le quotidien avant dans
tous les dans tous les services il y
avait des effectifs qui étaient on va
dire adaptés à la situation maintenant
on est tous en sous-effectif donc en
fait quand vous faites une garde de
sapeurs-pompiers dans une caserne vous
avez un volume horaire d'intervention
qui est bien plus important par pompier
c'est à dire que sur une carrière c'est
une usure encore prématurée je vais
prendre cet exemple là qui est qui est
parlant vous avez une voiture en fait
patiner les pneus voilà malponneux il
chauffe c'est notre cœur les pneus il
chauffe le lendemain il est refroidi
sauf que le pneu au fur et à mesure du
temps il s'abîme et ben nous c'est notre
cœur c'est exactement la même chose donc
à partir de là
le fait qu'on soit en sous effectif le
fait que un pompier il fait pas 35
heures il monte jusqu'à 48 heures par
semaine nous l'amplitude horaire c'est
2256 heures c'est une directive
européenne on ne fait le maximum du
temps de travail autorisé il y a des
pompiers en 24 heures quand vous faites
16 heures 17 heures d'intervention sur
une carte de 24 heures croyez moi le
lendemain vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes
pas en forme et les jours qui suivent
aussi donc à partir de là sur une
carrière complète ça use et ça tue les
gens notre espérance de vie en bonne
santé c'est 62 ans
pour par la cité vous avez derrière
d'autres chiffres deux études une qui
montre que notre on vit de six ans moins
longtemps que les travailleurs et une
autre qui dit huit ans on va vous dire
je vais vous dire 7 ans donc à partir de
là vous imaginez bien que à partir de 5
de 62 ans ça se passe pas très bien pour
nous partir à 59 voilà c'est notre
espérance de vie qui diminue et voilà
c'est exponentiel vous avez un truc que
j'aimerais souligner ou que personne ne
parle c'est ce qu'on appelle la toxicité
des fumées les pompiers vous voyez là
ils sont ils sont en contact
normalement il devrait avoir un appareil
respiratoire isolant pour se protéger
les poumons mais il faut savoir que la
fumée a pas sa trop à travers notre
tenue parce qu'en fait c'est tenu elles
sont très résistantes résistantes
mécaniquement sur les coûts voilà et sur
et pour la chaleur mais par contre la
fumée à travers ça rentre dans votre
corps ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
feux avant de
que faisait les pompiers c'était les
feux de vous savez les meubles de nos
grands-parents donc ça brûlait ça
mettait du temps à prendre ça durait
très longtemps et tout maintenant c'est
du vrai carburant qui brûle tous les
meubles ils sont c'est du carburant et
ils sont on fait beaucoup moins de feu
par contre ils sont bien plus toxiques
et ils nous apportent bien plus de
cancers et donc pourquoi je voulais
parler de ça ce soir c'est parce que
c'est un sujet qui est tabou ne
hiérarchie ne veulent pas en parler ils
commencent tout juste les médicaux quand
on leur pose des questions dans les 10
bien sûr on est départementaux ils ont
du mal à aller et à faire évoluer les
choses on commence à y avoir des
soubresauts on va dire soubresaut dans
ce sens là il y a une reconnaissance de
l'OMS liée justement la toxicité des
fumées sur les cancers des
sapeurs-pompiers la vessie la prostate
cancer du poumon
et donc bien sûr ça diminue notre
espérance de vie donc travailler plus
longtemps en gros c'est gentil c'est
bien c'est tout le monde paye sa cotise
à la société mais pour nous c'est pas
possible et c'est pour ça qu'on
acceptera pas et c'est pour ça que on
laisse on ira jusqu'au bout des choses
c'est à dire quand vous dites vous irez
jusqu'au bout des choses que vous êtes
vous êtes pompier si vous nous rejoignez
les 21h10 on est on est en direct on est
avec un pompier qui est un des pompiers
qui part à la manifestation quand vous
dites on ira au bout des choses c'est
vrai que quand les téléspectateurs et
les Français écoutent ça de la part d'un
pompier parce que dans la tête des gens
c'est vrai que les pompiers ils font du
côté de l'État et on dit voilà ils sont
là pour et c'est pour ça que parfois je
pense que il y a des gens voilà vous
l'avez dit qu'il qui vous investissent
parce que forcément ils se disent voilà
c'est ils essaient de faire leur métier
mais ils essaient d'arranger les choses
et c'est bien normal
mais c'est vrai que quand vous dites on
ira jusqu'au bout des choses ça veut
dire quoi bah nous on va pas casser on
va pas faire ça on va pas faire des
choses illégales vous vous en doutez
bien c'est à dire parce que on continue
à nous on continuera de voir vous pensez
vous pensez vraiment que
de continuer à aller dans la rue ça va
faire bouger les choses ou bien penser
parce que oui on en parlait il y a un
instant avec Alexandre il y a 30% en
moins de de de manifestants voilà de
gens qui viennent c'est ce qui qui
est-ce que les gens ont peur d'aller
dans ces manifs
bien sûr certainement ça donc c'est une
petite anecdote de la dernière manif
donc pas aujourd'hui celle d'avant il y
avait tellement de monde que il y avait
un service de comment dire de un
périmètre de sécurité qui avait été fait
par les forces de l'ordre et donc il y
avait des rues parallèles et tout donc
plusieurs fois on est rentré on est
ressorti donc à chaque fois on est on
était parti avec des du cortège des
syndicats après il y avait les jeunes et
après il y avait les Black Bloc voilà
les casseurs voilà donc on les a tous
fait qu'on est arrivé au niveau des
Black Blocs au début on n'avait pas fait
gaffe parce que on a pas une vision
globale de le de la manifestation on
était applaudit on est rentré dedans on
a fait environ 300 ou 400 mètres avec
eux à aucun moment on était insulté à
aucun moment voilà on était applaudi il
y a juste un moment où c'est parti un
peu en vrille où ça a cassé de tous les
côtés et bien évidemment on est sorti
mais on continuera à manifester mais
quand vous voyez au-delà au-delà même si
il vous applaudissent même s'ils sont
des mots gentils pour vous quand vous
voyez c'est c'est casseurs voilà
détruire des choses alors que parce que
c'est vrai que les pompiers ils sont là
pour sauver des vies ils sont là pour 1h
pour que le c'est pas un maintien de
l'ordre mais voilà c'est un non c'est le
maintien avec vous vous êtes là pour
voilà pour que les choses pour aider les
gens donc quand vous voyez les voyez
casser tout ça vous vous dites quoi dans
votre tête on se dit que on se dit que
bon ben voilà c'est enfin vous vous
doutez bien qu'on est nous on n'est pas
des cassé on a pas cet esprit là et euh
on n'est pas dans cette démarche là du
tout donc bien évidemment on cautionne
absolument pas ce qu'ils font après
après nous nous on le fera jamais ça
c'est une chose qui est sûr
mais derrière nous on n'a pas on n'est
pas tombé en face de situations nous on
a dû intervenir voilà merci
aujourd'hui vous allez continuer à
descendre dans la rue donc sur la
prochaine mobilisation bien sûr jeudi
prochain jeudi prochain on va nous voir
vous allez voir d'accord très bien